kamala harris losing the support of her
rabid online fan base the massive fan
base that is rabbit online it's the
latest embarrassing story to rock her
vice presidency a new report reveals how
disappointed die hard followers
known as and i just learned this the k
hive are suddenly vanishing supporters
who had high expectations have given up
on her administering of failures once
one self-described former member of the
group saying quote the disappointment is
real
ouch and hey it's no wonder her fans
want some distance a fox poll puts
combo's approval at a measly 39 percent
dana didn't she poll at less than one
percent in the democratic primary well
yes but she also quit in 2019 before he
even got to 2020 right she pulled out
they didn't have any more money and then
she got resurrected and she did become
the vice president of the united states
and i think these numbers though show
that people are disappointed with that
you know that she
all we've heard from the white house in
the last nine months as their poll
numbers have been so abysmal is that we
just don't communicate well enough
and our solution is we are going to get
out on the road out of dc and we're
going to go travel more and we're going
to go talk about all the great things
that we've done so this past week you
know they passed the house passes the
inflation reduction act i say in quotes
and guess where they are they're not out
there selling it they're both on
vacation
for a week and so i i think that their
communication strategy is lacking the
last thing i'd point out is we talked
about how
a year ago today there was the world was
in turmoil over afghanistan do you know
what she was doing
on this very day a year ago she was
spending her time with child actors
to make her look cool talking about
space
by a production call production company
called sinking ship entertainment and i
think that just was the metaphor of the
whole thing hey richard at the top of
the show you had that fly that was
buzzing around it really was actually
symbolic of her high moment which was in
that debate with mike pence and she made
all the funny faces do you think the k
hive built upon moments like that was
actually bigger than 12 the 12 they
interviewed for the story i mean that
was a good moment for her where she was
like you know i'm speaking don't
interrupt me mr vice president um i
think that was it was a great moment
it's probably one of the better vice
presidential debate moments in american
history
but with that being said i will not i
mean you can't here's the truth here's
what we also know about american history
there's never been a vice president that
was more popular than the president that
they were serving number one and number
two so if you have a presidential
approval rating that's in the 30s you
should expect that the vice presidential
approval rating is going to be in the
same space
so so it's joe biden's fault no i'm not
saying it's joe biden's fault i think
i'll be honest with you i think we're
hearing lies a problem i think that
there's been a lot of really if you were
to if this was barack obama's the the
the obama administration would have
loved to pass a bipartisan
infrastructure bill they got rid of all
the lead pipes in america that joe biden
passed the problem here is the american
people while you're replacing these lead
pipes it takes time to get all the stuff
done and so we have to wait for these
things to get done and to dana's point
they struggle with communicating that
dana i think that kamala was built upon
two things a social media moment a
twitter phenomenon which shows the lack
of reach of twitter now that she has no
popularity and the power of identity
politics which has a limitation when it
comes again to real world acceptance she
can't hang on to people who are getting
paid
of course people who are kind of
volunteering
i'm volunteering as your fan of course
they're of course they're going to hit
the bricks and go find somebody else to
worship she's at the point that she
needs to adopt a pet
and i don't mean get one i mean rescue a
pet like something like a bunny rabbit
that she can carry around with her
because it's better to be considered
strange and weird
than stupid and unpopular and so she can
just carry it around
it's stroking all the time yep greg how
many of you are left in the k-hive oh
god it's been tough for all of us i'm
staying i'm staying to the bitter end
richard's right though it's like the
vice president can't be more popular
than the president of the president's
unpopular so goes the vp but that raises
the problem for her if she ever runs for
president she's not going to be able to
find a vp that won't outshine her but
grace will have you in the k hive right
i'll be there but you know what uh this
is this appears that this reveals the
destructive nature of putting quotas
over merit you never know how well
somebody does their job until this and
you go well we know how she got the job
supporters claim that she's being held
by a higher standard uh by dent of her
race and gender
you got to think about that she was
picked because of her race and gender
it's the most obvious two boxes that
were ticked when you remember that biden
hated her because she called him a
racist on national tv his wife hated her
the public hated her and she still got
picked there's no higher standard there
was no standard
i went on brian kilmeade i want you to
do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now